ciao a tutti per chi non mi conoscesse
mi chiamo guglielmo e volevo nascere
etero oggi purtroppo per noi è molto
difficile trovare l'anima gemella sapete
perché perché se oggi cerchi un uomo
vero un uomo con le palle non hai
speranze se vuoi qualcuno con le palle
ormai devi andarci a trovare una donna
scusatemi si usa il termine con le palle
per descrivere una donna in gamba è una
frase che io odio super maschilista e
allo stesso tempo un falso storico avere
le palle non vuol dire essere una
persona in gamba e fidatevi perché corsa
la mia vita ho avuto a che fare con un
bel po di palle più delle volte sono
molto meno utili di quelle che appendete
al vostro albero di natale ma torniamo
al focus di questo video volevo nascere
etero essere gay è terribile sapete
perché perché se in una coppia etero ci
sono un uomo e una donna in una coppia
gay ci sono due uomini due solo adesso
mi rendo conto di quanto tiziano ci
aveste visto lungo ecco uno è troppo
poco due sono tanti la cosa divertente
nei miei amici etero è che si lamentano
costantemente delle loro ragazze cioè
sembra che parli di danzare sia stato
l'otto per mille che loro siano perfetti
e che debbano poverini subire le
angherie di queste povere pazze
optimisti secondo gli uomini le donne
sono troppo indecisa il che è anche vero
una donna solitamente non sa che cosa
vuole finché a un certo punto della sua
vita non lo capisce un uomo al contrario
sa esattamente quello che vuole e subito
chiarissimo farebbe di tutto per
ottenerlo farebbe qualsiasi cosa per
arrivare al suo obiettivo
finché a un certo punto non si rende
conto di non aver capito un cazzo
le donne sono complicate analizzo le
cose da troppi punti di vista si fanno
200 domande si danno 2000 risposte cari
uomini le donne non sono complicate al
massimo sono complesse voi siete un
telegrafo in un bunker in mezzo al
deserto lo sono l'ultimo modello
dell'iphone
il fatto che poi non sapete usarle è un
vostro problema di sicuro non loro le
donne sono ritardatarie è vero sì ci
mettono due ore a prepararsi il loro
concetto di bit è veloce in realtà è una
spal retto con massaggio linfodrenante
impacco di argilla verde è verissimo per
carità se chiede una donna di uscire
tutte le volte vero lei non saprà che
cosa mettersi una volta che esci con un
uomo il più delle volte
se non saprà cosa dirti sinceramente
preferisco le prime secondi le donne
pensano troppo era famiglie vogliono
troppo costruire invece gli uomini
rovinano tutto hanno la stessa capacità
di rovinare le relazioni che avevano i
protagonisti di piccoli problemi di
cuore sapete perché perché hanno paura
hanno paura quando le cose diventano
serie hanno paura quando le cose non
vanno come avevano previsto hanno paura
ad affrontare i problemi hanno paura
paura paura ma te che cazzo che
spaventate guardate che l'anello di
fidanzamento non c'entra niente con the
ring le donne poi sono matto e sì perché
perché ti dicono di sì che fanno il
contrario poi seguono quello che katy ha
detto l'amica va però agisco in testa
loro andrò a cagare lo stronzo poi sono
riprendono perché poverine non riescono
a mettere d'accordo la testa con la
pancia gli uomini sono peggio uomini
secondo qualcosa che sta pochi
centimetri sotto la pancia e che
prosegue per altri pochissimi centimetri
nelle mutande la testa se la dimenticano
proprio è troppo lontana dalle loro
centro cognitivo nascosto nei boxer
forse anche per questo che spesso ci
viene da battezzarla con lo stesso nome
della loro minchia le donne possono
attenta a tutto ti fanno mille domande
si ricordano le date e si lamentano se
loro partner non fa la stessa cosa
scassano le palle se non noti il nuovo
taglio di capelli se non noti come hanno
cambiato leggermente la loro linea di
eyeliner o il vestitino che hanno
comprato in saldo ragazzi ma poi vi
rendete conto del buco di culo che si fa
una donna per comprarsi vestiti e cioè
quelle fanno dei calcoli balistici
assurdi quelle small e kgb anni di
stretching al collo che riuscire a
girare la testa di 180 gradi e riuscire
a vedere i pantaloni che stanno provando
gli fanno un bel culo no unar massimo se
volete proprio fare uno sforzo da ero e
poi fate la doccia dopo che avete fatto
una partita di calcetto in mezzo
cinghiali perdonatemi se noti con mi
dispiace mette una mano sul cuore
ma se io potessi avere un telecomando
magico io adesso farei subito cambio
canale e passerella mia vita con una
ragazza che mi renderebbe felice e ci
uscirei le direi che bello smalto tesoro
da davvero preferire farlo piuttosto che
uscire con una serie di imbecilli e
prima che qualcuno possa prendermi
troppo sul serio e tira su questi sono
dei cliché
io vi dico che questo naturalmente un
video ironico da parte veramente della
prima persona che crede fortemente nel
uguaglianza nei vari diritti tra i sessi
sarà per questo che mi diverto
una cosa serve però ci tengo a dirla del
maggior parte degli uomini che che lo
ammetto non ho poi è convinta che quella
dei diritti sia una battaglia che
dovrebbero combattere solamente le
dirette interessate perché alla fine le
donne sono tragiche perché alla fine i
loro mondi sono distanti anni luce non
potranno mai capire quali sono i loro
enormi sforzi precari uomini lasciate
che vi dica una cosa che mi piaccia o no
l'altra faccia del maschilismo è il
machismo fidatevi che questa cosa vi
riguarda molto più di quanto non si
possa piacere
secondo alcuni critici infatti un uomo
non può piangere non può provare dei
sentimenti troppo forti non può
mostrarsi fragile o non può curarsi
troppo oppure non può avere degli
interessi che esulino dal calcio e dalla
[ __ ] perché se no altrimenti e una
femminuccia cari maschi conquistadores
se pensate che una donna sia solamente
questo si vede che non avete mai
conosciuto una ragazza in vita vostra
basta con questi luoghi comuni anzi se
pensate che essere simile una donna sia
una cosa negativa
chiedetevi perché siete soli e datevi
una risposta una risposta che molto
probabilmente tarderà ad arrivare visto
che dimenticherete
la domanda non appena sentirete la
parola derby ma tranquilli vi rispondo
io cari maschi che non devono chiedere
mai niente a nessuno
lasciatevi dare un piccolo consiglio le
persone che mi ci ha sempre chiesto in
tutta la sua vita la vostra prospettiva
è completamente sbagliata è il motivo
molto probabilmente è perché guardate il
mondo dal cavallo dei vostri pantaloni
quindi molto probabilmente mette gli
occhi foderati dai vostri stessi
genitali fatevi un favore fateci un
favore a tutti quanti spezzate le gabbie
nelle quali vi siete rinchiusi da sole
anzi una volta usciti aiutate anche gli
altri a spezzare le loro aiutate le
vostre compagne e le vostre fidanzate le
vostre mogli a spezzare le gabbie che i
vostri colleghi i vostri amici i vostri
fratelli vostro padre hanno costruito
per loro fate sì che la vostra
permanenza su questa terra abbia un
senso altrimenti avete sbagliato uscire
dall utero di vostra madre nel senso che
avete proprio toppato la strada è così
ed usciti dal buco sbagliato